the alarming new allegations about an
air National Guardsman accused of
leaking classified materials prosecutors
say that Jack text Sarah had a long
history of making racist and also
anti-semitic comments and also had
access to a large collection of weapons
he is due in a Massachusetts courtroom
later today and our senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge has
more on this from Washington she's been
following it Catherine good morning Good
morning Tony the 21 year old allegedly
shared classified military documents and
CIA updates on the social media platform
used by video Gamers and others to
connect online a Wednesday Court filing
by the justice department includes new
evidence that alleges a history of
violent and racist remarks
hours before Jack texiera's scheduled
court appearance Federal prosecutors
filed a memo arguing for his confinement
according to the 18-page memo Federal
investigators found a Gun Locker at his
mom's house outside Boston for the cache
of weapons and tactical gear surrounding
his bed prosecutors say five years ago
text Sarah was suspended from high
school for talking about weapons
mentioning Molotov cocktails and guns at
the school and making racial threats
that behavior was flagged to local
police when text Sarah applied to obtain
a firearm and the filing also alleges he
searched online about mass killings and
posted disturbing comments saying he
wanted Isis to quote kill a ton of
people the Department of Justice also
argues there was an attempt to interfere
with the investigation it claims texera
tried to cover up the leak by destroying
evidence like a laptop and game console
and posted in a chat group to delete all
my messages text Sarah's it job in the
National Guard allowed access to highly
classified material the Air Force
temporarily suspended two commanders of
his unit and stripped them of their
access to classified systems this week
National Security spokesman John Kirby
told CBS mornings that the scope of the
damage is still unknown
the truth is Tony that we don't and
that's obviously deeply concerning to
all of us we want to get as great a
grasp on the scope of the universe of
documents that are out there so it can
do a proper National Security assessment
of exactly what damage might be done
prosecutors say Tech Sarah should be
held pending trial because he is a
Flight Risk he faces 25 years in prison
connected to charges involving the
Espionage Act and there could be more
charges to come we've reached out to his
lawyer for comment but have received no
response Nate
we will stay tuned Catherine thank you